alright guys I'm here with judoka
super excited about this because you
guys are doing a bunch of stuff ledger X
that I think most people don't
understand which is options and so a lot
of people hear options oh yeah I know
what that is and have no clue so you are
here to demystify this entire world for
us so thank you for coming thank you
absolutely alright so let's start with
just your background
kind of what you did before ledger X and
then we can get into how you got New
Krypton things like that sure so my
training was math and computer science
um you know from an education point of
view and then I worked at Goldman Sachs
for seven years I spent five years doing
high-frequency options market making and
then two years doing an institutional
franchise trading I'm still in the
option space so I was in the option
space actually and then but about you
know halfway through my tenor at Goldman
my husband who's the CEO of Leger X was
on the west coast at Y Combinator doing
a start-up he'd actually left Goldman to
go do this startup and this was in 2011
when Bitcoin first kind of had its mini
price spikes that seems kind of crazy at
the time and so he is you know he got
exposed to it on the west coast and we
found it really fascinating from both a
you know technical and a financial point
of view you know it's both an asset
class and you know in obviously the
distributed decentralized nature of it
so we decided to sort of play around
with it a little bit you know try to
acquire some and I remember because I
was at Goldman wait to go through the
compliance department at MIT to move our
funds through Dwolla to eventually get
them to GOx and I think it took us a
good three to four weeks to actually you
know get our hands on a Bitcoin but as
soon as we did we could just send it to
each other you know across coasts all
the time seamlessly and you know we
started playing around with it almost
like kids and so that's when we first
got exposed to it it was still I mean
one could argue it's still the Wild West
today but it was really the Wild West
back then so we really just more
followed it and you know we're very
interested in it and then only a few
years later when it seemed a little bit
more mature
the time was right was when we decided
to start ledger X got it back then it
was really a test of your will right how
bad do you want this Bitcoin exactly and
then you know I mean and then at least
now there are best practices for storage
and stuff I mean at the time you just
have it on your laptop and you just kind
of hope you know
absolutely all right so let's let's talk
about what you guys are doing at ledger
X first and then we can get into kind of
options 101 if you will yeah absolutely
so we are a we're an institutional
platform we are federally regulated the
two kind of go hand-in-hand and that we
always knew in order to attract us
institutions and larger players we'd
have to have a license that they were
comfortable with and so the COTC is one
of the two federal regulators for
derivatives and they're the ones that
oversee us we are our licenses are for
an exchange in a clearinghouse in
exchange is what I think most people are
generally familiar with which is what
allows you to match trades so do people
come in to trade the exchange kind of is
the platform sitting in the middle the
Clearing House is more of the plumbing
and infrastructure that is actually more
important and I think you know a little
bit removed from you know from an
individual's experience but the Clearing
House is what allows you the license
that allows you to custody on behalf of
customers Fiat like US Dollars and
digital currencies like Bitcoin and so
that's what enables us to be able to
offer and provide physically settled
products is that week in custody the
physical and the the US dollars and be
that bridge let's walk through the
licensing process right what did you
have to do to apply and then why did you
guys get the license do you think over
others well it was it was a process so
we first it always is yeah so we first
applied in September 2014 and we you
know we took we actually I mean it was a
very big bet on the business we took the
big bet that we believed the CFTC would
be the appropriate regulator for you
know for digital currency derivatives
and that was not obvious at the time but
we saw a lot of analogies to other
commodities that they regulate and so we
submitted the applications and then we
spent about a good you know nine months
really just working with the CFTC on you
know on the jurisdiction you know of
Bitcoin and how we believed as a
commodity and about a year later in
September 2015 they gave us one of the
licenses the exchange license and they
also more importantly for us they
asserted jurisdiction over Bitcoin
derivatives as a commodity and they shut
down unregistered derivatives exchanges
that were you know that were in the
space and then you know then it was more
of a process to get them comfortable
with the custody of the physical so you
know took a while for us to finally get
you know the official licenses which we
got in July of 2017 but you know really
we started the process so early that you
know arguably maybe even too early that
the reason we are the only ones and the
reason we were first is just because we
were you know really far ahead of of
what we thought was gonna be the
appropriate path to be licensed okay the
most popular thing that people know you
for and they're using today is options
trading right what is an option an
option is the right but not the
obligation to buy or sell a product and
say let's say Bitcoin at a certain price
at a certain time so in the future in
the future and so you know you can
contrast it to let's say you just take
Bitcoin which people sometimes call like
spot but you know so Bitcoin you really
you can either buy it or sell it those
are the right now it's right now in real
time yeah in real time just for Bitcoin
itself you know you can just you buy it
and you can sell it and those are the
only two dimensions you know if you buy
it then you just hold it indefinitely
and if you sell it you know if you're
selling if you have it then you're out
of the position and to just because I
want to make sure that we're really
clear with people because I actually
think this is the number one thing that
people don't understand in the industry
that they pretend they do right is let's
say the Bitcoin right now
he's $5,500 price point right and when I
go to buy it I've gone to an exchange
and I'm the buyer you're the seller we
both agree you're going to sell me the
Bitcoin at $5,500 I own the Bitcoin and
if I do nothing forever I will hold that
one Bitcoin at a $5,500 kind of cost and
if it goes up or down in value it's just
worth what it's worth whenever I go to
eventually sell it to somebody else
exactly okay in that same scenario where
today Bitcoin is at $5,500 the option
does what so the options provide two
additional dimensions they provide a
time dimension so you can have an option
that expires a month from now a year
from now we have options out to June
2020 and then they provide a price
dimension so you can week they call it
the strike price but it's the price at
which you agree to buy or sell Bitcoin
so we can enter into a call option which
is a right if I buy it it's a right for
me to purchase Bitcoin at a certain
price on a certain date in the future so
an example would be we're sitting here
in November 2018 and bitcoins at 5500
you could buy a call option that says
June 1st 2019 I get the right to buy
Bitcoin at $6,000 and in that scenario
why would you do that why would you buy
that call option rather than just buy
Bitcoin yep
so the the call option the way that the
if you think about how your payoff on a
call option works if a call option is if
the if bitcoin is below $6,000 then you
don't make or lose any money so all you
you paid some price for the option and
that's it so if it's below $6,000 you
don't lose any more than what you paid
for the option using those numbers 5500
and the co options for 6000 let's call
it six seven months what would be the
normal ballpark price I would pay for
this call option
oh man I'm a little out of my my trading
days but let's call it $1,000 okay so I
basically pay $1,000 for the potential
to buy this in the future at
exactly and because the payoff is
asymmetric in that if it goes up a lot
you know if Bitcoin goes to 10,000 now
you know you're up $4,000 but if it goes
down to 2,000 you're not more you're not
out more than $1,000 you paid and so
because of that profile people might
from a risk point of view they might
prefer to have an option and you know
rather than buying Bitcoin itself and in
a way it provides a little bit of
leverage to them
okay that's a call option that's a call
is you're betting on the price to
increase by a certain amount at a future
date right a put option is what a put
option is the right again not the
obligation to sell Bitcoin at a certain
price on a certain date in the future
okay so $5,500 today I could buy a put
option that says June 1st 2019 $3,000
Bitcoin and why would I do that
so you might most people buy put options
as what they would call like protection
or insurance so let's say you have a
whole bunch of Bitcoin and you know you
might want to be you know you want to be
in Bitcoin for the long term but you
might be worried about in the short term
you know whether it's news related or
and and you know any anything that's out
of your control you might be worried
about the price going down in the short
term so you can buy some protections so
that if Bitcoin does go down to you know
$1,000 well now you can sell it at
$3,000 and so you you know you
essentially what people say it's like
hedged your position okay and what type
of people are normally buying and
selling these options so it's a really
wide range you know if I look at ledger
access customers in our institutional
base is everything from miners to
Bitcoin companies that are you know
either do merch in their consumer
services or building other businesses in
you know that rely on digital currency
to funds whether they're crypto funds
that you know popped up specifically for
crypto or even just traditional you know
family offices and hedge funds and then
to trading shops so if we look on the
let's start with call options if you
look at the folks who are buying call
options sometimes their volatility
traders and so you know with options you
can make a lot of different types of
bets and put on a lot of different types
of positions and so they might buy an
option for the volatility because they
think bitcoins going to move some funds
will buy call options because you know
in the same way that we were talking
about how you get some leverage and not
as much downside they might not want to
put a whole bunch of money into Bitcoin
right now but if Bitcoin does go up a
lot over the next six months then they
want to be able to perform they want the
fun to perform well and not underperform
so they might put you know have a lower
stake in Bitcoin but by some some call
options I think the you know the sellers
of call options are by far people who
either people high-net-worth individuals
or companies or miners who have Bitcoin
you know on their balance sheet and
they're not really earning any yield or
interest off of it sometimes they want
to monetize Bitcoin you know maybe they
would sell a little bit a Bitcoin at
fifty five hundred to pay their bills
and in what a call option allows them to
do is they can sell you know maybe eight
ten thousand strike call option and
pledge their Bitcoin against it and
right now you know today maybe they'll
collect five hundred dollars for that so
that thousand dollars that we talked
about earlier it cost to buy the call
option right so I want to buy that call
option I spent a thousand dollars to you
know June 1st 2019 $10,000 call option
it's at fifty five hundred today who
gets a thousand dollars so that goes to
the seller so the seller at the call
option on day one the seller receives
that thousand dollars and so they can
use that they can withdraw it from
ledger acts they can use it to further
purchases use it for whatever they need
and they get that today you know the day
that they sell the option and then you
know on the date that the option expires
if Bitcoin is above ten thousand then
they're set they'll sell Bitcoin at ten
thousand and receive ten thousand
dollars and if it's below ten thousand
and they'll just get their Bitcoin back
and so you know a lot of our a lot of
the customers who do these types of
trades they prefer that to just selling
Bitcoin at fifty five hundred today
yes speculation yeah and
and because bitcoin is you know even
though volatilities been lower now it's
still much more volatile than other than
you know other products out there with
options because options have the
asymmetric downside versus upside when
volatility is higher it makes options
prices higher and so the sellers can
collect more you know US dollars today
got it and so how does Lud Rex make
money we so currently we just charge a
transaction fee on you know what all
trades that are max on the platform okay
you've got a range of both call and put
options across the platform right so
some are short term highly volatile type
right some are long term low volatility
and everything in between
what are the most popular ones right now
the call options in general the the call
options at higher strikes than Bitcoin
price so what you know I'll call them
with up side call options those are by
far the most popular to give us an
example of one yep so the like at
December so even at December 2018 seven
thousand strike call option and then I
don't we said again a December 2018
seven thousand call option so people are
betting on today's fifty five hundred
dollar price is going to increase to
more than seven thousand before the end
of the year yep and and the way you know
one way to think about that bet also is
it's not necessarily just that they say
they're thinking about it like it's just
gonna be more than seven thousand part
of it could be that you know let's say
that that option costs like $50 if you
know you might say well if it is above
seven thousand I think it's gonna be a
lot more than seven thousand it's maybe
more than what I pay for the option for
sure yeah exactly you're gonna make much
more so they'll say you know okay maybe
I see some potential catalysts coming in
December and I don't know if they're
gonna move Bitcoin but if they do move
it up then you know I think Bitcoin
would go to ten thousand so that that
would be worth the three that that
option would be worth $3,000 got it okay
and then you guys have a really unique
derivative in that you've got this June
2020
right and so describe what it is and
kind of what the thought process was and
then we can get into how people are
planning it yeah so we have a number of
you know expirations that we
list and we have flexibility in terms of
where where we can how far out we can go
or you know even how near dated we do
see a lot of people especially with
short term news they trade you know one
month two month three month options and
we have a lot of demand further out and
I think one of the things that's been
really nice for us since we've been
operational for a year is we can you
know we can kind of observe and listen
to customers and see what they want and
a lot of our customers started asking
for June 2020
because of the having that's expected in
May 2020 and so these options allow a
wide range of customers from minors to
just speculators to individuals and to
companies to put on positions based on
how either a hedge that they might want
or how they believe the having would
affect Bitcoin prices so people are
identifying this moment in time to
having that there's historical precedent
in terms of how the market has reacted
and it can be interpreted a bunch of
whole different ways and so what people
are now saying is the next having is
going to have an event that can make the
market go up down sideways whatever what
you're basically allowing them to do is
to make bets or speculate on what is
gonna happen
so if I believe it's going to increase
in price I'm gonna make a certain
investment in options on that June 2020
expiration date and vice versa if I
think is gonna go down etc can I go onto
the platform and arbitrarily pick a date
or do I only have to use the dates that
you guys select so ledger X selects the
dates and the strike prices um and we do
that usually in response to an in
conjunction with where we think customer
demand is okay so for the 2020s the two
strike prices that there was most demand
for actually the $25,000 strike and the
$50,000 strike interesting so those are
the only two that we have listed there
in general you know part of the reason
we do that is when you have options
there's so many different ones that you
can list we want to concentrate the
liquidity so that everybody is trading a
lot of the same ones but we're usually
very you know we usually rely on
customer feedback and where participants
want to trade to drive what we
adaptively lists what what is it
currently look like in terms of how
people are playing that June 2020 option
do they is it the twenty five fifty
thousand calls puts what's more popular
the calls and you know I think in
general there's more buying demand for
sure got it so more people are buying
calls on a June 2020 option than
anything else yep and the the twenty
five thousand strike is the one that's
more popular got it what does it look
like today through this bear market
right so we've had seventy eighty you
know percent drawdown in the market it's
now gone on for almost 11 months from
kind of all-time highs have options
become more popular or less popular and
then what can you give some data may be
around you know monthly volume or
something like that that you guys are
seeing yeah are so overall our volumes
have grown approximately twenty to
twenty five percent month-over-month
year-to-date so it's been you know in a
variety of different market environments
and I think you see that with options in
general the what people usually talk
about and you know when they think about
derivatives and options is okay if the
market goes down a lot or goes up a lot
you know options are very active and
that's absolutely true and we've seen it
recently on our platform in the last
week as well but I think one of the
unintuitive elements is even if the
market is kind of trading range bound or
not moving that much we're seeing a lot
of customers come in to options because
they want to either
you know earn some yield off their
Bitcoin if they think okay we're gonna
see another you know 2014-2015 where
we're kind of flat for a while they want
it you know monetize the position a
little bit more and you know for
speculators too or for traders and for
funds it provides more types of
positions that they can put on if they
may not have conviction about you know
buying or selling Bitcoin itself right
now got it what do you think most
institutional investors right now
believed to be precluding them from
participating the options market right
so what's the thing that's holding it
all back well I think institutions is
such a broad term you know can apply to
such a wide range of you know financial
institutions so ledger acts is an
institutional platform which again
can apply to Bitcoin companies actually
high-net-worth individuals can qualify
and then obviously your traditional
trading shops and funds so we you know
we launched with 15 institutions October
of last year and now we're up to 160
institutional participants Wow so you've
gone from 15 160 in about 13 months yeah
and it you know we continue to see
really steady growth there so we're
seeing institutional involvement but you
know at the same time I mean the there
are against such a wide range of
institutions that if you are a fund
that's managing you know 20 30 billion
dollars then there might not be enough
opportunity necessarily for you to get
into the space but for the institutions
that are you know up to 500 million
dollars there's easily enough
opportunity and liquidity that makes
sense for them now so I think as you
know it'll just continue to grow where
the market will be interesting to
different sets of institutional
participants until it really gets up to
what I think people are considering
considering like the very large
institutions got it and then from like a
monthly volume or or what does that look
like it's what's growing but are we
talking tens of millions hundreds of
millions billions of dollars a month
what do you see from the volume side
probably between 50 and 75 million
dollars a month yeah and again primarily
in options we do have a next day Bitcoin
product which allows people to buy and
sell Bitcoin which in many of our
customers use out of convenience and
because the fees are very low but
obviously options are where it's a you
know particularly unique offering got it
what do you think in terms of other
derivative products right so you guys
you're in options you're kind of the
first federally regulated options here
in this market are there other things
that are interesting on the derivatives
side kind of where do you guys see the
business going over time yeah I think
there's two I see two different areas so
you know what we're doing right now with
options I think it's an important
product it's important for the ecosystem
but you know in some ways we're not
really you know it's we're kind of
taking things that have worked from
other markets very traditional vanilla
products and bringing them to Bitcoin
because they make sense and so we'll
continue to do that and you see that
happening in other areas of
ecosystem with people working on ETFs
and stuff like that but at the same time
you know further down the line as the
markets mature I do see opportunity for
derivatives products that really are
unique to Bitcoin and cryptocurrency um
and so we'll definitely explore those as
well
got it and right now the options are
just Bitcoin or you have options across
other digital assets currently ours are
just Bitcoin was there a strategic
reason kind of you know fundamental
belief as to only to do that or what was
the logic behind just bitcoins well so
part of it is a regulatory question so
the you know things that would fall into
like I SEOs and things that would fall
into the SCC's domain you know that's
not our area or the license so whereas
we're specifically in the CFTC you know
area of focus and so within that we have
we have Bitcoin you know we have again
built out I want to say this carefully
we've built out the functionality for
aetherium but it's really that's up to a
determination of if that you know
eventually ends up being a commodity
under the CFTC so it's really um it's
really regulatory but at the same time I
think overall you know where we kind of
see this playing out is having really a
handful of digital currencies with
different trade-offs and probably not
like hundreds of them and so you know
focusing on that handful got it how do
you compete with the fidelities the
backs of the world right these people
who are coming from the legacy financial
world you know you and your husband
obviously come from that world but you
start a new company okay so you kind of
start from scratch not from knowledge
but but from resources and headcount and
all of that how do you compete with the
big guys who come in right do you think
that there's a you know I'm assuming
there's advantages and disadvantages
right but but how do you think about
that you know we really see ourselves as
kind of straddling both coasts you know
Nepal spent a lot of time on the west
coast and I think there's there's a lot
of benefits to it to both sides we want
to bring those both in our model is in
we control the entire process so
everything is vertically integrated
which allows both a seamless customer
experience but it also gives us ultimate
control over how quickly we can
incorporate feedback and incorporate
what we see whereas in the traditional
world usually you have to go through
intermediaries that either
control the interface or route the
orders or you know that you have to
integrate with legacy technology and so
for us that allows us to provide a
really seamless experience that we can
iterate on really quickly and that we
can observe and follow exactly how
people are using the platform and I
think one of the biggest advantages that
we have right now is that we have been
operational for a year and so we've had
a lot of time and a lot of data and a
lot of feedback to work off of that is
informing a lot of our ultimate product
decisions that will come out that other
folks just don't have because you can
only get that by really having a product
in front of customers
got it what keeps you up at night right
I'm sure there's a whole bunch of things
but but building a business in the
crypto space that's heavily regulated
right given what you guys are doing deal
with institutional customers and then
there's this element of like time
sensitivity just by the nature of the
product you sell right because there's
options with an expiration date what's
like the number one thing that you know
you just sit there and you're like oh
this is what I'm worried about or
working on well I mean I'd say the one
of the biggest it just the things that
are outside of our control that
ultimately affect our business and
affect what we have to you know do so
you know we are because we are so highly
regulated and we value our relationship
with regulators even if there's headline
risk or if there's something that
happens in some area of the world that
may not directly affect ledger X but you
know affects the Bitcoin space those
usually become problems that then we
have to you know we have to deal with
and so there's obviously a lot of stuff
out there that we can control a lot of
ways that a lot of things that are being
done that we may not necessarily agree
with the approach but they ultimately
end up being things that we have to we
have to face in all areas of the
business whether it's you know with with
customers investors regulators and
there's I think there's going to be that
for a while that you know headline risk
until things are really
institutionalized absolutely you come
from Wall Street right and working at
Goldman
do you have any sense for how your
former colleagues whether they still
work at Goldman or not how they look at
this are they interested in it are they
you know rushing to the door and they
want to jump into the industry are they
you know you guys are crazy for going
and building a business in the space
kind of where do they shakeout I mean I
obviously can't speak for you know
Goldman everyone at Goldman but just
over jet are overgeneralize people from
from that industry yeah overall I think
it's there's a lot of interest but you
know it's it's a little bit removed from
you know from real I would say you know
operations and building businesses and
really getting into the space there's
some amount of I mean people are always
looking for interesting things to trade
on the side but that I would say is more
interest in terms of a tradable asset
that is new and different as opposed to
real interest in you know the
cryptocurrency space and ecosystem it's
interesting because you know you
basically took something that exists in
the legacy financial system and you're
applying it just to a new asset right so
there's a lot of crossover but you still
have to find people who are excited
about the asset who have long term
belief in you know this niche of Finance
and then ultimately really are betting
on not just it to survive but actually
to thrive in a really big way yeah and I
think part of it is if you look in you
know New York for example the a lot of
it's a hard for a lot of people to
really get excited about some of the use
cases like payments for example you know
people who have JPMorgan Chase accounts
like their credit cards work just fine
so they're not sitting there you know so
so they're kind of the the use cases to
them are not as clear now obviously you
can imagine many two billion Bank people
many cross-border payment use cases that
are interesting we actually think you
know the use case that we're focused on
that is uniquely possible because a
Bitcoin is Bitcoin as a form of
collateral
you know that's at the Clearing House we
take it as collateral and it's not just
so that we can physically settle trades
but it people can pledge collateral to
the Clearinghouse 24/7 365 and just
start trading and that's something if
you look in the traditional world that
you just can't do
limited by banking hours my weekends by
holidays and so you know I think it's
really there has to be something more
driving it than just you know being
interested in the price for sure you get
to go to work everyday with your husband
what's the most fun part about that I
don't get asked many people that
question because they just want that
situation what's the most fun part about
it well it's I mean over boats we've
actually worked together you know a lot
in the past probably the best thing
about it is that you have a significant
other that understands you know
everything that you're going through
whether it's you know it's good or bad
but I think also I mean just really
being in sync you know the it's they
kind of say on the west coast that
co-founder relationships are kind of
like marriage and I think when it you
know when it works it does really work
because you have to be a in this sort of
space and in startups in general you
just have to be so in sync and so on the
same page whether it's about the
ultimate vision or the day-to-day he and
I actually the bet like the the thing
that really works well is were just
complement each other very well he's
really good at stuff I'm not good at I'm
better at stuff he's not good at so it's
it's just a really good working
relationship but it's just lucky that's
awesome
all right before we wrap up as much of a
kind of fire around questions if you
will
what's the most important company in
your opinion in crypto other than ledger
X a good question I don't want to I
don't want to show any favoritism to I'm
gonna not answer the question but answer
it I don't wanna show any favoritism to
customers but um we're really excited
about Lightning Network and a lot of
things that we can do with the
Clearinghouse you know once that's more
mature god I forgot ask you this where'd
the name come from Paul just came up
with it on I remember weirdest Starbucks
waiting for to go to pitch a VC and he
just came up with it on a napkin and the
domain was available so we went with it
innovation is sometimes birthed out of
necessity right we gotta come up with
the name let's go that's awesome all
right if you could wave a magic wand and
change or improve any one regulation
what would you change
good question I mean I would say in the
u.s. just this bifurcation between
everything that's going on with the you
know in the ico token world and in the
commodities world which is you know
Bitcoin and aetherium it's just it it
makes it companies basically just have
to choose one or the other because of
the two very very different regulators
what do you believe in crypto that you
think the highest majority of other
people would disagree what's your most
controversial thought I actually so I
still think that it's not mature enough
for the very large institutions why you
know I think the if you look at I mean
even a lot of the if you if you're
looking at people who are gonna put real
money into this you know there's not a
lot of infrastructure that's actually
been established I think if you look at
like spot exchanges for example the spot
exchanges are traditionally you know in
the crypto world they're overseen by
states and estate licenses I don't think
states are appropriate regulators for a
financial exchange and we haven't really
you know and I think you see that lead
to things like when you see flash
crashes and when you see things that are
just not normal in the traditional space
and you know so I don't know if it's
gonna take time or if it's just going to
be that you know like platforms like
ours kind of as we continue to evolve
but I yeah I just don't think that those
areas are as mature as they need to be
interesting what's the most important
book you've ever read that you think
every single person I go read right now
well since we're talking about startups
I mean if you're doing a start-up you
got to read the hard thing about hard
thing I've been Horowitz for sure and
then you got to read it like every few
months cuz different parts of it will
resonate with you every few months he
really did a fantastic job with that one
especially just making it actionable and
and I think you know when you're read I
suppose when you're putting a company it
ought to be walk away just like it'll be
okay you'll figure it out any any crazy
stories from as you guys have been
building the company that you were just
like this is insanity they were doing
this I mean we only almost bounced
payroll about a dozen times in
fifteen 2016 when everyone was focused
on private blockchains and permissioned
Ledger's and we were still really
focused on Bitcoin we're not selling
derivatives on a technology and it's a
difficult environment but you know got
through it a dozen times you guys did a
pretty good job but we never did we
never did miss apparel but it is very
close that's amazing all right so I'll
end every interview letting the guests
ask me one question what one question
would you ask me I didn't warn you about
this see well what's the most which is
the most interesting podcast that you've
done so far outside of this one of
course well yeah of course this one so
I'm gonna answer this imma cheatin give
you two so the most interesting I think
because people didn't understand
anything about it we did one with Travis
clink and Travis talked about you know
algorithmic market making washed trading
kind of all of the nuances of exchanges
and various activity and kind of how
price manipulation works and just things
that I think people they read a headline
again yeah kind of know that is but
actually know what wash Trading is so I
listen to the podcast and get an
explanation and go tell all my friends
and they're like I'm smart type thing
but but he just has a really good
command of how that stuff works and also
how it is being leveraged today so he's
able to talk about specific changes how
it works the most important podcasts
we've recorded is with Murad and we
basically laid out the ultimate case for
Bitcoin and you know somebody asked me
the other day why do I think that
podcast specifically was so popular and
kind of got such wide distribution and
you know I really think that he did a
good job of not only explaining what is
Bitcoin why is it important and you know
here's kind of the things you need to
know but he really expanded people's
imagination of what is possible if
adoption continues right and so you know
he threw out a ten million dollar
Bitcoin price in the future well that's
much much higher than most people have
heard in terms of you know as you've
heard 100 200 250 thousand five hundred
thousand ten million is almost like
ridiculous in their mind and then he
walked it back and said this is how I
think we get there is this impact on the
world and the interesting thing about
that episode in particular is the the
breadth of type of person who listens so
everyone from I have know nothing about
Bitcoin my friend sent me this and so I
start listening to highly sophisticated
people that you and I would know that
are public and you know most people say
you know they're expert or they have
expertise in the space they still found
it highly compelling because it's just
such a you know it pushes the envelope
so far right so I think that you know
with this episode specifically people
don't know what options are they
actually have no clue how they work they
don't know why they're important they
don't know who would use them and so you
know our hope with the podcast is just
that you know while I learn you know
other people can learn alongside us and
you know people haven't stopped
listening yet so we'll see what happens
absolutely but awesome
thank you so much for coming this is
super exciting I think that what you
guys are building is obviously really
important and congratulations I kind of
all the growth to date and hopefully we
can keep doing this as you guys kind of
periodically keep progressing yeah
thanks a lot it's a lot of fun
you